what is start to happen right now is
everybody's being affected by the pull
you know politically correctness the PC
movements affecting everybody so it's
tough to be a comedian today I mean you
got a Dave Chappelle that goes and does
it stand up and you know oh my gosh
death you can't say something like that
what do you mean when he's given is I
don't know if you've seen it or not I
watch it twice I couldn't believe how
amazing it was on how we explained
everything so I don't know how long this
is gonna last on the politically correct
I think eventually they're gonna be like
look we can't just do this somebody
needs to go out there and say so but
we'll see what's gonna happen what do
you think about that how long do you
think this could last I think it depends
on how how long we are successful as a
country I think that political
correctness
generally speaking or as a whole is a
direct reflection of a country
successfulness if you look at any other
countries we'll take your your place of
birth as an example political
correctness really doesn't exist there
at least not anywhere near in the same
realm as it does here why is that or if
take a look at the Philippines or
Indonesia or
any places where their GDP is is a
fraction of what ours is and most of the
day-to-day struggle is in survival why
don't they have it there well because
they don't have the leverage the
flexibility or frankly the luxury to be
pissed or offended by certain words
because it doesn't matter because
they're too busy worried about just
surviving and so our country has been so
successful for so long no different than
say the Roman Empire
having having a similar fate and that
you know it's the the cycle of hard hard
times create hard men you know and you
know the rest but you you get to a
certain point where it's been so easy
for us for so many generations to where
now it's inevitable so to me it's it's a
correction is coming of some sort
whether it's another country whether
it's a natural disaster whether it's a
coronavirus type of pandemic who knows
but to me the only the only way that I
really see that that political
correctness umbrella being lifted off of
our society is is a
huge kick in the nuts frankly is is that
that's what it's going to take for
people to say you know what who cares
about words I got it I gotta feed my
children
[Music]